the Indiana Pacers will celebrate the
30th anniversary of Hoosiers by wearing
the film's chicory uniforms during
select games this season paulie's
actually wearing the uniform the George
Hill wore during the press conference
there and then you have to send this
back to the Pacers right Paulie unless
mr. bird allows us to yeah Larry how do
you think you would look in those
uniforms I couldn't fit in any uniform
right now give me a couple months on my
bill fit in one but George looked pretty
good in it
so I think it's going to be a big hit
for us explain that whole phenomenon of
Hoosiers that in Indiana that the small
school is competing against the big ones
even your your how small was your high
school I don't know we want to smallest
in the state what happened what what it
is damn back in the day back when I
played they were we didn't have class
basketball now they do so the dream was
to always be able to be good enough to
play in sorry about that play against
the big schools and that's what we try
to do we try to be good enough to maybe
have an opportunity one day play against
the Crispus Attucks or Jeffersonville or
New Albany but unfortunately I played
with the kid that kept missing free
throws at the end of the game and we
didn't get there what wait was there a
hacker Shack going on with your team
back then well with my point guard he
got a little nervous and they knew it so
they started fouling him and we just
didn't make it you're not over it are
you never you know what the loss is a
loss and a big loss but hey you know
what's funny I was at a party about two
years ago and a party of the cookout and
this lady's been her 70s she looked at
my friend says what are you doing here
he goes why come the cookout she was
after missing in Fritos back in 74 you
should even show your face now just been
35 years I understand that but that
happened damn yeah but that's it's so
important to the fabric of a town there
I mean yeah I mean it was that was
everything back then of how good the
basketball team was yeah
not just a basketball but sports back in
the day you know I mean they went to
football games basketball games and our
gymnasium held 2800 and we used to get
4300 in there but it you know I mean
it's big Indiana basketball especially
in my hometown back when we we plan not
only me but my brothers and my cousins
and all that it was a big it was a big
deal it's not as big now because of
class but I don't think it's just
because of class basketball but the
excitement and tear the teams are not as
good how biggest are were you in high
school
well I mean there's how many billions of
people they are in China they all knew
me well know in high school that's why
I'm saying high school they knew who you
were in China sure they did Dan okay
nobody knew about me in the States but
my second but it's kinda know I was from
a town of 2,000 people 10 I was 6 1 it
says a sophomore 6 3 as a junior and 6 7
as a senior you know I mean I averaged a
lot of points a lot of rebounds and won
a lot of games but I don't know I didn't
go around and you know ask people if
they knew I noticed that you averaged
only four assists your senior year in
high school now they did that by
quarters yeah
everything they do it always by Corps
really ya know so you averaged look but
16 assists there oh I'm sure I did man
well I don't know I don't think so
because guys couldn't make less they
made all the layups yeah but I did have
a pretty good team I played on my
teammates for good in high school we
just couldn't win the big one how would
things be different for you would they
be different if you were coming out of
high school now yeah
oh I don't know it would be as much fun
but would you be a one-and-done no I
don't think so I don't think I would do
it Dan when I was 18 Jesus Christ it's a
little different now these kids are seem
like more mature the body's filled out
you know they're ready for the challenge
I was never there's no way I could come
out at 18 19 years old go to the pearl
but when did you know that you you were
you had that ability to be something
different that you could play it
possibly play in the NBA well when I was
in the summer I was at rookie free agent
camp in Boston they had some veterans
there and they played a couple days with
us and I know it's just summer I know
it's not in the games and no but I know
I remember one day I walked out and I go
I'm not gonna have any problem this
league that's the first time I really
felt that you know growing come from a
small school high school then went to a
mid-major you know there's always doubt
people always told me what wait you get
to the pros this and that but it didn't
take long it didn't take long for me to
feel that I could pack a play in this
league did you see that story about I
guess it started with Shaq and Scottie
Pippen on the all-time Bulls team
against the old-time Laker team and Jack
and Scottie were going back at each
other and then then people started
looking at if I had the old-time Celtic
team against the old-time Laker team how
would that work out did you follow that
story at all no but you know I see
things all the time I mean who really
cares people really care about that I
think they like to argue it yeah it's
court one error you're in though I mean
in 80s they always think that people
from that era think that that was the
best time for basketball and now you
know it's completely different
well why was it so much better the
appearance it was so much better in the
80s than it is now well the parents is
because most of the big stars came out
then you know Jordan Pippen Jordan had
his run he had Carl Malone John Stockton
Charles Barkley and Patrick Ewing Chris
Mullin and me just go to the you know it
just goes on and on and on and I mean
there's a lot of great players
I said Thomas Kevin McHale you know just
from the mid eighties early the 83-82
all the way through there just so many
names that people can recognize with and
I think that's why they think it was the
best time and
to me I always felt our 8016 - how could
you get anything better than that but
I'm sure there are teams out there were
better than that but the style though of
what was played in the 80s is what made
it so much fun well the style was there
was two different styles there's either
the beat down the east and there's a
run-and-gun in the West and you had to
be able to play both styles to win a
championship that's why that's why I
always liked it in the East you know
against New York you know Philadelphia
people don't talk about Philadelphia's
great teams they've had grad great teams
in the 80s early 80s as a beat down then
you go the Lakers you know they walk
through the championship every year out
there then you had to go against Sam and
you had to score 125 points a game to
win so how would you done in the Lakers
style oh we got a lot of sleep after the
game I can tell you that beautiful tired
well that's a lot of running yeah I can
beveren 84 we they were in a
championship game we were playing them
they had us down in a CEREC mexico said
something to me about hey you can't beat
what you can't catch run for bath but
you guys ran with them when you play
them in the end but that wasn't our
style I mean we could do both styles but
if we did it all year long yeah I
wouldn't been a big deal but you know we
really we did it we go on the west coast
trip for two weeks we knew it was going
to be up and down running gun and all
that but then you go through the
playoffs and you know you score 100 508
points games all sudden you're up 225
that's a whole different ball game
Michael Jordan said he could beat
anybody on his roster pal yes oh gee
come on he believes it though well you
can believe what everyone but I said
there's no way and what's it say about
his roster Larry if we can beat
everybody on the roster I don't know if
he can do that or not he had to prove
that to me these people when I got with
this stuff go dance
that's like no you going to tell on your
radio shows that you could beat me
one-on-one
I don't know this redic I could score on
you hey bikes cool okay I just want you
on record I just want proven okay if we
played to 21 well first of all I'm not
playing the 20 okay go by three okay
we'll go bite I like about 10 we'll play
to 10 okay
no make it take it oh well that's no
well no I can't
there's no make it take it how do I do I
need to say this is probably 10 date all
right fair enough
cuz I just sit down and take a break
when you got the ball was there and was
there ever a point though after when you
were coaching that you were better than
somebody on your roster back when I was
40 no I don't know about that
what about shooting oh yeah yeah yeah
ain't no problem okay but was there a
point where you were the best shooter on
the team and you weren't on the team you
were coaching the team no I Reggie
Reggie was here crystal chrismole and
Sam perk there's pretty good shooters
okay but after those guys left well I'll
get an older after they left
wait you were just on that Jordan
letting it go yeah you can still take
these guys and shut up nobody take them
on or not then I mean you know you
talking about I would say I was probably
40 yeah 40 and Reggie them guys were
coming into her prime and Chris was a
little bit older Sempron no I couldn't I
had a hard time staying with Chris
Mullin Wow
shooting with him back my in Olympics
when I was playing an Olympics try are
not trial to the game but do you see
Steph Curry can you say after four or
five years that he's the best shooter
that we've ever seen I don't know about
that Chris Mullin was pretty good you
just getting out there shooting around
you mean game shots I don't know even
how you characterize it because when
somebody says if I say the best deep
shooter in the game yeah I'd say he's
prayer cuz you know there are so many
good I mean people
don't even know who Joey hasit is and
he's one of the best deep shooters I
ever saw know or Conner Henry was good
Bale Ellis I mean there's so many guys
in there how about Mark Price and you
know there's something I always thought
deep shooter occurs about one of the
best would be who would be in the
conversation though are you in the
conversation yeah sure I am okay
he says Bess or something yeah did i
insult you by asking you that okay good
now I'm consoled Reggie Miller yep
Reggie hit as many big shots if you go
back and look over over the years as
anyone
he's a tie the game or are go up by one
or win the game as many as anybody I
mean I've seen it I played against him
and I coached him he's hit a lot of big
shots so there's something to be said
for the guy who does it when you have to
have it done
that's right those those guys that can
do it for the first three quarters all
right well the thing is you know anybody
can shoot it one's tied it's when you're
down one or down two I mean how many
guys make that shot I know that you know
they're people like you and Jerry
whether there's certain guys that it's
not in their DNA to to not try to win or
tank
I just how do we how do we prevent
tanking in the NBA well there those I
don't know I don't have the answer but
mine I've always said these teams has
been in the lottery for more than three
years should have to sit out one time
and what they would do they would trade
that pick away when they knew it was
coming up then they get back in again
the next year there's there you know
there are league's full lawyers they can
come up with something well I was
wondering if you did this once you're
eliminated the more wins you have after
you're eliminated the more ping-pong
balls you get well many nights now think
about it but if you say it along with
you then
who's calling you right now when you're
trying because you know tomorrow they're
gonna have a big story Larry Bird said
but you really said it I disagreed with
it is that Jordan calling you right now
probably I want to play me one-on-one
yeah could you take Jordan right now
could I take Jordan where's this going
what kind of where my Hickory uniform
yes you can well that'd be a good game
Jordans gonna wear his North Carolina
jersey and you're going Hickory Hickory
a one-on-one with Jordan yep kind of
hate to admit this but he killed me I
don't know if I honestly believe that
but then I come 40 pounds more and I was
when I played I'm broken down I really
don't care like I used to I don't I have
a fight in me but it's not the fight
that I once had but it'd be a pretty
close game hey thanks for joining us
with the the Hickory uniforms and should
be great 30th anniversary of Hoosiers
the Pacers will celebrate that with
select games next season wearing those
Hickory uniforms don't be awesome Damon
thank you thanks for having good to
catch up with you Larry thank you lovely
all right that's a labor on the Famer